[Musica]
alzi la mano Chi ha fatto almeno una
volta uno di questi sacrifici per una
vita sana alimentazione
attività fisica
meditazione
prevenzione medica
Ok
Sai qual è uno dei più grandi paradossi
della nostra società
facciamo tanti sacrifici per vivere il
più a lungo possibile e poi abbiamo
paura di invecchiare
Ma perché abbiamo questa paura di
invecchiare
la natura ci insegna che il ciclo della
vita dà il suo meglio proprio verso la
fine pensiamo per esempio
al bruco che nasce strisciando poi
invecchia e impara a volare fino a
diventare una bellissima farfalla oppure
pensiamo semplicemente alla giornata che
dà il meglio di sé proprio al tramonto
con quei colori meravigliosi per
l'essere umano funziona esattamente allo
stesso modo
me lo hanno insegnato tante anziani
straordinari e coloratissimi una in
particolare mia nonna Lisa ferz non so
quanti di voi hanno un rapporto speciale
con la propria nonna Io con mia nonna ho
sempre avuto un legame unico in
particolare dal 26 settembre del 1989
quando mia madre la sua unica figlia è
venuta a mancare all'improvviso a 28
anni io avevo quattro anni e mezzo nonna
ne aveva 59 e lei dice sempre che quella
è la prima volta che li ho salvato la
vita Io dico che è stato esattamente il
contrario che è stata lei a salvare la
vita a me ma lei insiste dice che le ho
salvato la vita per tre volte
La seconda è stata quando all'età di
vent'anni ho deciso di andare a vivere
insieme ai miei nonni dopo che lei era
caduta rompendosi il femore La terza è
stata quando nel
2017 lo aiutata a sollevarsi dalla
depressione per cui era caduta in
seguito alla morte di nonno dopo 64 anni
di matrimonio in modo insolito con un
profilo Instagram io prima le avevo
provate tutte per risollevarla ma non
c'era verso non aveva passato gli ultimi
dieci anni chiusa in casa con nonno
affetto da una brutta forma di demenza
senile si era isolata per fare con lui
sempre con dolcezza e con il sorriso
versare con il suo grande amore quando
nonno poi era venuto a mancare nonna si
era sentita persa si sentiva inutile
diceva che la sua vita non ancora più
senso Si sentiva un peso per la famiglia
e per la società l'unico modo che ho
trovato è stato invertire la formula
sono diventato io a chiedere aiuto a lei
nonna Guarda Ha aperto questa nuova
pizzeria Mi piacerebbe tanto provarla Ma
nessun mio amico vuole venire e io mi
vergogno a mangiare da solo Ti va di
venire con me oppure nonna Guarda ho
comprato la nuova macchina fotografica
non so bene come funziona ti va di
aiutarmi a fare delle prove e così con
queste prove a marzo del 2018 ho
pubblicato il suo primo post su
Instagram nonna da subito Ha ricevuto
tantissima affetto tantissimi commenti e
messaggi che le dicevano sei bellissima
sei meravigliosa grazie per l'allegria
che ci porti e le chiedevano tanti
consigli e foto dopo foto messaggio dopo
messaggio dopo il tempo insieme nonna
sera finalmente risollevata dalla
depressione ed era tornata felice già
Questo potrebbe essere un finale ma
quello che è successo dopo è ancora più
straordinario più o meno un anno dopo da
Monaco di Baviera Selina una designer di
gioielli ci scrive perché voleva nonna
per la sua campagna pubblicitaria stava
selezionando modelle giovani e anziane
per dimostrare che la bellezza delle
donne non ha età sarebbe stato
meraviglioso però Cavolo viaggiare non
aveva 89 anni era troppo grande per
viaggiare era pericoloso poi nonna
Comunque sia è cardiopatica
all'artrite la maculopatia due protesi
alle anche sarebbe stato meglio evitare
fortunatamente Selina ci teneva così
tanto ad avere nonna in questa campagna
che venne lei a casa nostra a scattare
queste foto ci chiese anche quanto
volevamo ma noi non abbiamo voluto
niente perché tutto questo gioco su
Instagram era nato per far vivere a
nonna qualcosa di diverso e per
distrarla L'unica cosa che chiedemmo
furono i diritti di queste foto fra cui
il diritto della foto che ha cambiato
per sempre la nostra vita
quando Selina è venuta a casa nostra ha
proposto a nonna di posare in desabie
per far vedere che la bellezza delle
donne non scade come lo yogurt nonna ha
accettato subito entusiasta di essere
ambasciatrice di questo messaggio e
inaspettatamente Questa foto è diventata
virale ha fatto il giro di media in
tutto il mondo e così nonna 89 anni era
diventata improvvisamente una modella
professionista e l'influencer più
anziana d'Italia
io da quel momento mi sono sentito
l'uomo più ricco del mondo perché se
avessi potuto comprare qualcosa avrei
comprato del tempo con mia nonna e aver
fatto del nostro tempo un lavoro mi
permette di stare con lei tutto il
giorno e per questo sono infinitamente
grato la vita questa foto anche portato
diverse critiche Perché la nostra
società non è pronta ancora a vedere la
vecchiaia femminile pensiamo che il
complimento che si fa più frequentemente
a una donna Ge è sei ancora una bella
donna come se vecchiaia e bellezza non
potessero convivere ma con nonna abbiamo
lottato anche contro questo nonna si è
ritrovata essere un attivista e da quel
momento quello che abbiamo vissuto è
stata una cosa incredibilmente ancora
più straordinaria e straordinario
avevano iniziato
a confondersi era normale viaggiare con
nonna in giro per l'Italia vederla a
posare per servizi fotografici per
riviste andare in televisione ricordo
però il momento Esatto in cui ho
realizzato quanto fosse straordinario
quello che stavamo vivendo era un
pomeriggio grigio d'autunno ero sul
divano con mia moglie e mi arriva un
messaggio vedo risponde poco Mia moglie
mi fa Chi era dico niente amore era
Andrea mi ha chiesto come si chiama il
vibratore che hanno regalato alla nonna
ci siamo guardati e siamo scoppiati a
ridere realizzando quanto quello
ordinario e quello straordinario si
fossero ormai mischiati Ma la cosa più
straordinaria è stata la lezione che mia
nonna mi ha dato ovverosia realizzare
che la vecchiaia non è una malattia non
è cardiopatica quando abbiamo iniziato
questo percorso nel 2017
invece non aveva il 25% di efficienza
cardiaca stava per lo più a casa non
aveva una vita particolarmente Attiva
anche la sua rete sociale era abbastanza
ridotta poi che cosa è successo abbiamo
iniziato appunto a viaggiare e a vivere
al massimo e quando siamo tornati dopo
qualche anno dal cardiologo a rifare
l'esame siamo rimasti sconvolti nonna
nel 2021 aveva il 40% di efficienza
cardiaca oltre a sembrare molto più
giovane L'anno dopo siamo tornati ancora
a fare la visita con il timore che tutto
andasse bene era ancora migliorata
ma quello che ci siamo chiesti Allora
era che cosa è cambiato grazie a mia
nonna è cambiata la mia visione della
vecchiaia io prima credevo che per stare
con mia nonna dovessi andarla a trovare
a casa convinto che era bene farla stare
tranquilla ignorando che quella che io
chiamavo tranquillità lei la chiamava
monotonia ed è tossica nonna mi ha
insegnato che quello che serve è essere
attivi
è buttarsi Io mi sono accorto che avevo
sbagliato La mia paura più grande Io ero
convinto che la mia paura più grande
fosse che nonna morisse invece era come
se avevo paura che nonna vivesse
l'organizzazione Mondiale della sanità
insiste molto sull'invecchiamento attivo
perché dice che l'invecchiamento globale
della popolazione comporterà richieste
sociali ed economiche alle quali
bisognerà far fronte mantenere la
popolazione attiva e dunque una
necessità e non un lusso e per
proteggere i nostri anziani dobbiamo
guardare la loro sicurezza la loro
partecipazione attiva alla vita
comunitaria e la loro salute Intesa non
solo come fisica ma anche come benessere
mentale e psicologico Chi ha la fortuna
di avere ancora i nonni o i genitori o
anche un vicino di casa anziano
particolarmente simpatico che cosa può
fare di concreto Credetemi basta
veramente poco per esempio mettere delle
nuove abitudini delle nuove routine come
quella di andare a mangiare fuori
insieme è inimmaginabile l'impatto che
può avere andare a mangiare fuori
insieme
Primo perché avere un obiettivo a breve
termine a cui aggrapparsi è fondamentale
per ogni persona anziana è uno stimolo
così come sono tantissimi di stimoli del
pranzo fuori i sapori gli odori
incontrare nuove persone ascoltare
storie e per di più questa abitudine ci
aiuta anche a rispondere a una delle
domande che nonni e i genitori fanno più
di frequente ovverosia Ma quando ci
vediamo basta mettere questa nuova
routine mi rendo conto che è difficile
per chi vive lontano dai suoi anziani ma
c'è il piano B che è ancora migliore
viaggiare in famiglia viaggiare per gli
anziani è fondamentale tutti quanti
benefici deve andare a mangiare fuori
insieme Nel viaggiare sono amplificati
solamente la notizia di fare un viaggio
con i propri anziani è un qualcosa che
porta allegria solamente avere
quell'obiettivo è un qualcosa a cui
aggrapparsi per non parlare
dell'esercizio mnemonico della
pianificazione del viaggio pubblico
delle piccole responsabilità che si
possono dare per esempio nonna guarda i
biglietti del viaggio li tieni tu per
continuare a far sentire i nostri
anziani utili e attivi ci sono degli
Studi che dimostrano addirittura che
anche solamente ricordare e parlare di
quel viaggio una volta che si è tornati
rilascio endorfine Quindi almeno un
viaggio all'anno anche un weekend ha un
valore fondamentale una può pensare Ok
ma è difficile viaggiare con una persona
anziana Non è vero È facilissimo e
meraviglioso le compagnie aeree o
ferroviarie Fanno di tutto per
facilitare la vita qui c'è mia nonna che
per il suo compleanno per i suoi 93 anni
le ho fatto una sorpresa e l'ho portata
per la prima volta in volo ha preso un
aereo per la prima volta la stessa nonna
che io cinque anni fa dicevo nonna non
può viaggiare troppo vecchia oggi prende
gli aerei
viaggia ed è più viva che mai questo è
uno dei sogni della nonna che ho
realizzato ma abbiamo un sogno ancora
più grande e per realizzarlo abbiamo
bisogno dell'aiuto di tutti quanti
sogniamo un mondo in cui vecchio o
vecchia non sia più un dispregiativo
sogniamo un mondo in cui non ti dica più
sei ancora una bella donna o una società
che non definisca coraggiosa una signora
di 90 anni che si mette il costume per
andare a fare il bagno al mare per
cambiare tutti insieme la visione di
vecchiaia basta mettere in pratica i
consigli che ho dato prima oppure in
maniera molto semplice A natale invece
che regalare ai nonni pigiama o
pantofole regaliamo una bella camicia
colorata con la quale uscire regaliamo
un weekend in questo modo potremo
sperimentare in prima persona gli
straordinari benefici
dell'invecchiamento attivo e così
riusciremo a essere non solo grati per
essere la generazione più longeva della
storia ma anche la prima generazione che
vede la vecchiaia come un traguardo e
non ha più paura ricordandoci
che l'essere umano fa parte della natura
e la natura ci stupisce sempre verso la
fine come per esempio dopo un giorno
grigio di pioggia con un tramonto
coloratissimo questo perché la natura sa
che la bellezza della vita è
inseparabile dalla sua fragilità e per
questo dobbiamo viverla senza paura fino
all'ultimo giorno in realtà questo non
me l'ha insegnato propriamente la natura
me lo ha insegnato una forza della
natura La forza della natura che più mi
ha insegnato nella vita e che ho il
piacere e l'onore di presentare mia
nonna Lisa pers
[Applauso]
Grazie
nonna
a 93 anni come in te come te lo sanno
pochi ma com'è la vecchiaia la vecchiaia
È bellissima dalla gioventù passi alla
vecchiaia sono come le stagioni
dell'anno devi cogliere il lato migliore
e ce ne sono tante e durante la stagione
nonna che cos'è Che cosa significa per
te viaggiare
viaggiare è una cosa che mi esalta si
apre la mente lo spirito e sono
curiosissima conosco molte persone e mi
piace quando vado nelle città e nei
posti andare proprio
conoscerla per bene andare dei posti che
non ci va nessuno e io voglio sapere
tutto perché a quest'età ha più capisco
meglio è
nonna
[Applauso]
Nonna nonna tu sei la persona che più mi
ha insegnato nella vita sia con
l'esempio sia con la pratica volendo
insegnare qualcosa a tutte quante le
persone che sono qui Qual è
l'insegnamento più grande che puoi
lasciare io credo che queste persone non
abbiano bisogno degli insediamento ma
devono seguire la mia strada ad non aver
paura della vecchiaia perché la cosa più
bella che ci sia o lere bene a se stessi
alle altre e fare del bene più possibile
e non criticare mai nessuno e aiutare il
prossimo perché come dici sempre
senza amore senza amore non si vive
l'amore quello che ti dà la vita ti dà
la gioia di vivere e tu nonna me ne vado
all'infinito Grazie
Guarda che io voglio ancora vivere a
lungo eh finché non è il momento voglio
avere tutte le gioie ancora che ci sono
nella vita e le avrai e andare anche a
tutti gli eventi perché Guardate che
bello
mi piace Grazie grazie
[Musica]